TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER WHAT ELSE I
FAKE.
HERE NOW WITH REACTION IS FOX
NEWS LEGAL ANALYST GREG JARRETT
AND SOMEONE WHO WAS IN THE
COURTROOM TODAY, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE WITH US,
GREG, I WANT TO START WITH YOU
BECAUSE OH MY GOODNESS, HILLARY
CLINTON PERSONALLY SIGNED OFF O
THIS, PERSONALLY.
HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF?
>> SHE PERSONALLY APPROVED THE
SCHEME TO PEDDLE PHONY COLLUSIO
INFORMATION TO THAT MEDIA.
IT DROPPED LIKE A BOMBSHELL BY
HER OWN CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
IT SEEMS SO INCREDIBLY FOOLISH
FOR THE DEFENSE OF ALL PEOPLE T
HAVE CALLED HIM TO THE WITNESS
STAND VERY TO FUNDAMENTAL IN
TRYING CASES NEVER CALL A
WITNESS TO THE STAND THAT ONLY
HELPS YOU A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
THE DOWNSIDE OF HURTING YOU
TREMENDOUSLY IS QUITE SEVERE,
AND SURE ENOUGH, THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENED.
HE HELPED A LITTLE BIT,
MARGINALLY BY SAYING WELL, WE
COME, THE CAMPAIGN DIDN'T PUT U
ASSESSMENT GOING TO THE FBI TO
LIE TO THEM.
WHAT THE CAMPAIGN INTENDED IS
IRRELEVANT, WHAT IS MATERIAL IS
WHAT SUSSMAN'S INTENT WAS IN TH
INTENT HAS BEEN TO INSTRUMENTS
TRADED BY THE EVIDENCE AND THE
TESTIMONY, HE PUT HIS LIGHT TO
THE FBI IN WRITING GREAT NOW
HE'S ONLY LEFT WITH SOME RATHER
VACUOUS DEFENSES, HE CAN SAY
WELL, WHY WAS AN ITSY-BITSY LIE
MEANING IT WASN'T MATERIAL AS
REQUIRED UNDER THE LAW, THAT'S
NONSENSE BECAUSE THE FBI WILL
SAY ARE YOU KIDDING, WE WOULDN'
HAVE EVEN HAD THAT MEETING WAS
SUSSMAN HAD BEEN KNOWN TO TRUTH
PRETTY COULD ALSO CLAIM THAT
WHIPS DEFENSE, I DIDN'T INTEND
TO LIE, I JUST MISSPOKE, IT MAD
A BIT OF A MISTAKE.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO FLY EITHER,
AND FINALLY, HE IS GOING TO
CLAIM I THINK THAT THE FBI
FIGURED OUT HIS LIE SO IF THEY
KNEW IT WAS A LIE, HOW CAN THAT
BE A GENUINE LIE UNDER THE LAW.
THAT WOULDN'T NORMALLY WORK IN
FRONT OF A NEUTRAL AND FAIR JURY
, BUT YOU KNOW, JASON, THIS
IS WASHINGTON, DC.
>> IT IS WASHINGTON, DC.
YOU WERE ACTUALLY IN THE
COURTROOM, WHAT WAS THE
ATMOSPHERE LIKE?
HOW DID THE JURY REACT?
WHAT DID THEY HAPPEN TO THE
ATMOSPHERE THERE IN THE
COURTROOM WHEN IT WAS REVEALED
THAT HILLARY CLINTON HERSELF
APPROVED OF THIS SCHEME?
>> WE'VE ALL BEEN WATCHING THIS
FOR DAYS AND I PLAN ON BEING
THEIR EVERY SINGLE DAY TO MAKE
SURE I HEAR EVERY BIT OF
TESTIMONY.
THIS WAS AMAZING, I NEVER HEARD
SO MANY PENS CLICK AND
IMMEDIATELY START WRITING, I GO
REPORTERS ASKING ME FOR
CLARIFICATION, WHAT DID THAT
MEAN, WHAT DID THAT MEAN HIM AR
THEY IN TROUBLE.
I SAID HE JUST CUT IT RIGHT TO
THE TOP AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WHAT YOU DID TODAY.
MADE IT VERY CLEAR THERE WAS A
PHONE CALL, SHE PAID FUSION GPS
THROUGH HER CAMPAIGN AND LAWYERS
, AND THAT SHE WAS
ACTUALLY TOLD THAT THERE WERE
PAPERS PROVIDED THAT HAD NOT
BEEN VERIFIED, AND HE SAID, WE
HAVE NO DNS EXPERTISE, WE JUST
FIGURED THAT MEDIA WOULD TAKE I
AND DO THEIR OWN VENTING.
REMEMBER THAT MEDIA THEY WENT T
WAS LATE, IT WASN'T THE NEW YOR
TIMES IT WASN'T THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL WHICH MAY BE IS A LITTL
MORE SOPHISTICATED, IT WAS LATE
GREAT ON TOP OF THAT, THIS WAS
THE SAME TIME THAT SHE WAS THE
LEADING DELETING E-MAILS AND
HAVING HER OWN PROBLEMS WITH HE
SERVERS, SHOW SHE AND HER TEAM
HAVE BEEN OCTOBER SURPRISE AND
THIS HAS BEEN A REAL BIG THEME
BY THE DURHAM TEAM, AND IT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED.
OCTOBER 31ST IRONICALLY SHE
RETWEETS THEY TWEET THAT ALL MY
GOD, CYBERSECURITY CRIMES, TRUM
HAS A SERVER WITH ALPHA BANK,
COMPLETE LIVE.
TO GET YES, THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF QUOTES I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
FOR EVERYBODY HERE.
THE FIRST WHEN I THINK IS FROM
ROBBIE MILK WHO IN HIS TESTIMON
AND LOOK AT WHAT HE SAID HERE.
HE SAID TWO OR THREE OF THE MOS
DAMAGING DAYS OF THE CAMPAIGN
WERE CAUSED BY TOLD MING, NOT
TRUMP, AND THE OTHER ONE IS VER
INTERESTING.
IF THE ELECTION WERE ON TOBER 27
, I HAPPEN TO BE THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AT
THE TIME THIS HAPPENED, AND THE
LETTER WAS ACTUALLY ADDRESSED T
ME AND SOME OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AND I THOUGHT ABOUT IT
I LOOKED AT IT, I SPENT ABOUT
HOW POWER OF MY GENERAL COUNSEL
LOOKING AT THAT.
AND, OY, THAT SENT THEM
SCRAMBLING BECAUSE TONY STEPPED
IN IT AGAIN AND GAVE US THIS
INFORMATION AND WE GAVE IT TO
THE PUBLIC.
>> THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY ROBBIE
MOVED TO INJECT POLITICS INTO A
CASE ABOUT EVIDENCE AND THE LAW.
TO TRY TO UNDULY INFLUENCE THIS
PRO HILLARY CLINTON JURY WHICH
WE DISCOVERED DURING JURY
SELECTION.
AND, IT IS ALSO RATHER
DISINGENUOUS BECAUSE HE IS
TRYING TO SUGGEST THAT WE WOULD
HAVE NEVER GONE TO THE FBI WITH
THE COLLUSION STORY WHEN IN FAC
HE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS SHOW
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY DID.
MOREOVER, JAMES COMEY YOU WILL
RECALL WAS HILLARY CLINTON'S BF
ON JULY 5TH OF 2016.
HE STOOD BEFORE TELEVISION
CAMERAS AND SPENT ABOUT TEN OR
15 MINUTES DESCRIBING HOW SHE
VIOLATED THE LAW WITH HER E-MAI
SERVER, AND THEN IN A COMPLETE
ABOUT-FACE IN THE COURSE OF TEN
SECONDS HE SAID, BUT NO
REASONABLE PROSECUTOR WOULD EVE
BRING SUCH A CASE, THAT'S HIS
JOB, HE'S A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL, HE'S NOT A PROSECUTOR.
IN THE END, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE FOR AN ABUSE OF POWER I
USURPING THE AUTHORITY OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SO THIS IS HIM TRYING TO TURN A
CASE ABOUT EVIDENCE AND THE LAW
INTO PURE POLITICS FOR
INEQUITABLE.
>> I THOUGHT COMEY WAS WRONG.
FOR SOMEBODY HE'S NOT CHARGING,
TO GO AHEAD FORWARD UNTIL ALL
THE PLACES HE BROKE THE LOCK,
HONESTLY I THINK THAT WAS
FUNDAMENTALLY WRONG.
WANT TO COME BACK TO YOU IT
COMES DOWN TO THAT 12 JURORS AN
SO RELEASED TO SUSSMAN.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
ATMOSPHERE AND HOW THE JURORS
ARE REACTING TO THIS.
HOW IS THE PROSECUTOR RECEIVED?
IS HE THE RIGHT PERSON WITH THE
RIGHT MESSAGE?
IS IT TOO MUCH ABOUT TRUMP?
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE COURTROOM
?
>> THE PROSECUTOR IS I THINK
DOING A FANTASTIC JOB.
THE DURHAM TEAM HAS BEEN VERY
ARTICULATE, THEY WENT UP, THEY
WERE BRIEF, AND THEY HAD GOTTEN
WHAT THEY NEEDED AT THAT POINT.
THE MEDIA IN THE NON- LEGAL
ENTITIES AND THE ROOM PROBABLY
DIDN'T FOLLOW IT AS WELL, BUT H
WAS ON TOP OF IT.
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE SUSSMAN
DEFENSE WAS THERE HAVE BEEN
TIMES WE'VE SEEN HIM BECOME
DEFENSIVE, WITH JIM BAKER, WE
SAW BERKOWITZ BECOME VERY ANGRY
AND REMIND BAKER THAT DIDN'T YO
SAY, SUSSMAN WAS YOUR FRIEND,
DIDN'T YOU SAY SUSSMAN WAS YOUR
FRIEND, AND TRY IN SOME WAYS TO
INTIMIDATE HIM AND THAT WAS
BECAUSE JIM BAKER SAID VERY
CLEARLY THAT MICHAEL SUSSMAN 10
AND IN PERSON THAT HE WAS NOT
THERE FOR ANY PLANES, AND THAT'
REALLY ALL THEY NEED TO PROVE,
THERE'S ONLY ONE COUNT HERE.
THE JURY IS OUT WASHINGTON JURY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO KNOW WHAT I
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THEM UNTIL
WE SEE WHAT THEIR VERDICT IS,
BUT I THINK IT'S BECOMING VERY
EVIDENT WHAT HAPPENED WAS 100
PERCENT WRONG, THEY MISLED,
THEY OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE IN THE
ENTIRE FBI WAS IN ON IT RIGHT
AND THE CAMPAIGN AND THE DNC.
A GAT